in this video we're going to talk about
how to graph rational functions and I'm
going to give you a process if you're
new to this how to work through these
problems we're going to go through five
examples we're going to talk about how
to find the asymptotes how to find the
intercepts how to find out if there's
any holes in the graph or slant
asymptotes how to plot some additional
points how to do some sign analysis to
get a pretty good sketch of these
rational functions we're going to go
through five different examples let's
dive in the first example f of x equals
x minus 2 over x squared minus x minus
6. if you want to practice go ahead and
pause the video and try this on your own
but the first thing I like to do is
Factor the rational function as much as
I can so the numerator we can't really
factor that that's going to stay as x
minus 2. the denominator though we can
Factor this trinomial what two numbers
multiply to negative 6 but add to
negative one well that's going to be
negative 3 and positive 2. now the
reason I
after this is because if a factor in the
numerator cancels with a factor in the
denominator what's going to happen is
we're going to have like a whole like a
removable discontinuity or a missing
point in our graph in this case there's
nothing that cancels numerator and
denominator and no factors so that tells
us that there's actually going to be no
holes in our graph so I'll just write
none for
holes okay now when you're talking about
rational functions just so you know
rational just means a ratio so it's like
a fraction Okay so we've got like a
polynomial divided by a polynomial
now when we talk about the vertical
asymptotes
well when you look at a fraction you can
never divide by zero right because
that's undefined so we can see here that
if x is equal to 3 3 minus three is zero
and so that would be make this undefined
same thing here if x was negative 2
negative 2 plus 2 is 0. so what happens
here is we're going to have vertical
asymptotes at x equals three and x
equals negative two now what I like to
do is as I figure things out over here I
like to kind of graph it as I go so x
equals 3 is a vertical line right here
and x equals negative 2 is also a
vertical line going through
negative 2. okay so now let's talk about
the horizontal asymptotes or the slant
asymptotes so when you're analyzing
whether it has a horizontal or a slant
you look at the highest power term in
the numerator
and the highest power term in the
denominator now if the denominator's
degree is higher than the numerator's
degree then the horizontal asymptote is
going to be the line Y equals zero okay
and the way to understand that is
Imagine as X gets larger and larger like
if I put in 100 for x 100 squared is 10
000 right and this is a hundred a
hundred divided by 10 000 that's going
to be a very small number it's getting
closer and closer to zero so what that
means is as you actually it's large and
large as you go to the right whereas X
goes to let's say negative Infinity go
to the left this whole fraction is going
to get smaller and smaller it's going to
go to zero and so that's why we have our
horizontal asymptote of y equals zero
now you might be saying Mario what about
these other terms here well you can see
this x squared is growing faster than
this x so as X gets bigger and bigger
this term is going to basically outpace
these guys here same thing in the
numerator this is going to be growing
much faster than minus two so as X is
really big this kind of Acts more like X
over x squared and that's how we're
getting that horizontal asymptote here
which in this case is right at the
x-axis I kind of like to put the
asymptote kind of like in a little bit
of a diagonal like that just so that I
can see it it doesn't blend in with the
x-axis
okay now for the y-intercept so
y-intercept means where does it cross
the y-axis well that's going to occur
when X is equal to zero okay because
when your X is zero not going left or
right you're just along this vertical
y-axis here so if I put 0 in for X
that's going to cancel out this term
this term and this term so anything that
has an X in it those guys are going to
cancel out and you can see we have
negative 2 divided by negative 6 which
is one third so there is our y-intercept
zero comma one-third which is right
about here
now for our x-intercept we do the
opposite we set y equal to zero and in
order for f of x or y to be equal to
zero the only way this is going to be
zero is if the numerator is zero right
because if you have a fraction the
numerator is 0 and the denominator is
not zero that whole fraction is going to
be equal to zero so a shortcut is just
to set the numerators factors to zero
and that's going to give you 2. so in
this case we have an x-intercept of 2
right here now for some students that
might seem a little bit confusing so
what you might want to do is you might
want to do this you might want to say
well uh Mario said set y to zero so
that's going to be f of x is equal to
zero zero is like zero over one right
because anything divided by one is
itself that's still going to be zero and
then over here we have x minus 2
over x minus 3 times X Plus 2. now you
know the cross product where you
multiply in the diagonals so zero times
this quantity gives us zero and x minus
2 times 1 is itself and then if we add 2
to both sides you can see we're getting
x equals two that's another way to do it
it's just to do that cross product
okay now we've got some pretty good
framework here we have our vertical
asymptotes we have our horizontal
asymptote we have our intercepts the
thing to focus on now are some
additional points to help us to get a
good graph here
now what's interesting is
you can cross a horizontal asymptote but
you cannot cross a vertical asymptote
and the reason is is because if x was
negative 2 we talked about this earlier
it would be dividing by zero it's
undefined same thing over here with 3.
so what happens is when you approach a
vertical asymptote it's like a brick
wall you either have to turn up towards
positive infinity or down towards
negative Infinity you can't go through
that vertical asymptote so what I like
to do is I like to pick some points on
either side of the vertical asymptotes
and what we're going to do is what's
called sign analysis so for example if I
pick like a negative 2.5 okay let's just
put this in our table here negative 2.5
I'm going to just put it in this
factored form right here so negative 2.5
minus 2 is negative 4.5 but I'm just
going to write it as a negative okay I'm
not going to focus on the number I'm
just going to focus on whether it's
negative or positive negative 2.5 minus
3 is negative 5.5 that's negative
negative 2.5 times R plus 2 is a
negative 0.5 that's negative and notice
what we have here negative times a
negative is a positive
a negative divided by a positive is a
negative so what that tells me is that
negative 2.5 this graph is going down
towards negative Infinity now if you
want to get an actual number go ahead
you can certainly do that but the main
thing is it's going down as you get
closer to this vertical asymptote and
when you go this direction you're
approaching this horizontal asymptote at
y equals zero so you can see here we're
getting this branch of the graph now
let's pick a point on this side of the
vertical asymptote maybe let's do
negative 1.5
so if we plug in negative 1.5
we get a negative 3.5
a negative 4.5
and a positive 0.5 so now look what we
have we have a negative times a positive
which is a negative in the denominator
negative divided by negative is a
positive that tells us when we're
approaching this asymptote from this
side it's going up
towards positive Infinity so here you
can see the graph kind of looking like
this right now let's pick a point on
this side of the vertical asymptote
maybe 2.5
so if we plug in 2.5 Let's see we get a
0.5 which is positive
2.5 minus 3 is going to be a negative
2.5 plus 2 is a positive and you can see
a negative times a positive is a
negative
and a positive divided by a negative is
a negative
and that tells us this is going down
towards negative Infinity so you can see
this branch of the graph
looks something like that and then over
here let's pick maybe uh
maybe four been easy one so if we plug
in 4 what do we get we get positive in
the numerator
4 minus 3 is positive
4 plus 2 is positive so we're getting a
positive divided by a positive which is
a positive that tells us this is going
up towards positive Infinity
and then it's approaching the horizontal
asymptote as X gets larger and larger so
you can see we have a pretty good sketch
of our graph the only other question
your teacher might ask is like what's
the domain of this rational function and
again we said that the denominator can't
be zero okay so it can't be three or
negative two so you could say all real
numbers
X cannot be will be saying negative two
or three that's one way to do it or if
you're doing interval notation you could
say it goes from negative Infinity
up to negative 2 not including negative
2 then it goes from negative 2 to
positive 3 not including so that's why
we're using the parentheses and then
from positive 3
onto positive infinity and that would be
your domain so let's take a look at
another example okay now for example
number two we've got x squared minus 9
over x squared minus x minus 12. so
what's the first thing we want to do we
want to factor it as much as we can so
the numerator is a difference of two
squares so we factor that as x minus 3 X
plus three a sum indifference pattern
the denominator it's a trinomial with
the leading coefficient of one so we say
what two numbers multiply to negative 12
but add to negative 1 that's going to be
let's see minus 4 and plus 3. and the
reason we do that is because we're
looking to see if there's any factors in
the numerator that cancel the factors in
the denominator and in this case you can
see that X Plus threes are going to
cancel and what that tells us is that
we're going to have a hole in our graph
if you set X plus 3 equal to 0
and solve we get the x coordinate of the
whole which is negative 3. to find the y
coordinate of the whole we take the
negative 3 and we put it back in to
what's left here so we get a negative 6
over a negative 7 which is
6 7. so let's go ahead and plot that on
our graph so negative 3 6 7 is almost up
to one but not quite so we'll just write
about here that's our whole
now as far as the graph is concerned
it's basically like graphing y equals x
minus 3 over x minus 4 because these
factors cancel the only added feature is
that there's going to be a hole in the
graph now if you graph this on your
graphing calculator because this is just
like a
infinitesimally small it's just like a
little pixel you're not going to see the
hole but if you go to your table you'll
see that there's an error at negative
three like you just it can't be negative
3 because we can't divide by zero now
even before you cancel these factors out
like this
you might want to analyze the domain we
said you can't divide by zero that's
undefined so you can see that the domain
is going to be all real numbers but X
cannot be negative three
and it cannot be four because that would
make the denominator a zero right
so you could also write it like this
from low to high negative Infinity to
negative 3 and then from negative 3 to 4
and then from 4 on to positive Infinity
okay now if we talk about the vertical
asymptotes we say we can't divide by
zero right so what would make this
denominator zero would be x equals four
because 4 minus 4 is 0. and so we're
going to have a vertical asymptote right
here at
4.
right here at four so now you might be
saying well what about here negative
three uh that would make the denominator
zero but that's where our hole was
located so it's either going to be a
hole or a vertical asymptote but uh not
both so now let's look at the horizontal
asymptote or the slant asymptote here's
where we focus in on the highest powered
term in the numerator the highest power
term in the denominator now if it's a
tie like see how these are both x
squared then what we do is we take the
ratio of the coefficients in front of
those variables so in this case this is
understood to be a one and a one so one
divided by 1 is 1 and our horizontal
asymptote is going to be right here at y
equals
one now you might be saying Mario why is
that well what happens is X gets bigger
and bigger like say if we put X is 100
in way over here to the right this term
is going to go faster than this term
this term is just going to stay at
negative 12. so as this gets bigger and
bigger this term is going to be much
more influential these are going to not
really have much of an effect as X gets
really big same thing with the negative
9. so this really reduces or acts like x
squared over x squared anything divided
by itself that's going to cancel out and
you're left with 1 over 1 which is the
ratio of the coefficients the last
example remember how the denominator's
degree was higher that's y equals zero
you're going to get it's going to get
closer to zero which is the x-axis and
we're going to do some examples where
the numerator's power is greater by a
power of one and that's where we're
going to get the slant asymptote so
that's coming in the the next examples
so now for the y-intercept
what we do is we set x equal to zero so
if I put 0 in for X that's going to be
negative 3 over negative 4 which is
three-fourths so that's going to be
right about here
now you might be saying you know why
didn't I use this one I could use this
one too if I put 0 in for X all these
are going to cancel out negative 9 over
negative 12 is also 3 4. just that the
graph is basically going to look like
this with the added feature of having
that hole there
now with the x-intercept we set the y
coordinate to zero and again remember
the shortcut is the only way that Y is
going to be equal to zero is if the
numerator's factors are equal to zero so
if I set x minus three equal to 0 I'm
going to get x equals three
which on my graph is going to be right
here
now you might be saying oh I don't like
that method Mario so you could say well
okay Y is equal to 0 which is like zero
over one
remember our graph is going to look like
this reduced function x minus 3 over x
minus 4. you can cross multiply remember
on the diagonals zero times anything is
0 x minus 3 times 1 is itself and if you
add 3 you can see you're getting x
equals three some students like this
much better
now we need to apply some additional
points but remember we can't go through
this vertical asymptote it's like a
brick wall either graph either has to go
up towards positive Infinity down
towards negative Infinity right how do
we know what's happening let's pick some
points on either side let's pick 3.5 and
like 4.5 or maybe even five so let's do
3.5 first
so I plug in 3.5 I'm going to get a
positive in the numerator this is the
sine analysis 3.5 minus 4 I get a
negative in the denominator a positive I
by negative is a negative which kind of
makes sense this is going down down so
you can kind of see this graph is going
to look like this
okay and you got that Branch now if we
do five that's going to give us a
positive 2 over a positive one positive
I by positive is a positive which tells
us from this direction we're going to be
going up towards positive infinity and
then we're going to approach that
horizontal asymptote as we go to the
right and you've got a good sketch let's
take a look at another example okay
let's take a look at example number
three now we've got this polynomial
divided by a polynomial rational
function first thing we want to do is
Factor right so in the numerator it
looks like we can factor out an X
as the greatest common factor and if we
do that we're going to be left with
let's see 2x squared plus 3x minus 2.
the denominator we can factor it's going
to factor to x minus 3 and X Plus 1.
this trinomial can factor a little bit
further so that's going to factor as
let's see 2X and 1X
and let's see this is going to be plus 2
and minus 1.
and then we have our denominator x minus
3x plus 1. okay so basically our
equation is going to look like this guy
right right here let's Circle that
okay in factored form
so the first thing we want to analyze is
are there any factors in the numerator
that cancel with factors in the
denominator if there are we know there's
going to be some holes in our graph in
this case there's no factors in the
numerator that cancel the factors in the
denominator so we're going to say that
there's no holes or none
okay now for the vertical asymptotes we
know we can't divide by zero so if we
set these factors equal to zero in the
denominator x minus 3 equals zero X plus
one equals zero we're going to get x
equals three
and x equals negative 1. so let's go
ahead and plot that on our graph here so
negative 1
try to be real
accurate about this so here's negative 1
and x equals 3 is going to be right here
just trying to draw it as a dash or
dotted line you won't actually see that
on the graph it's just kind of using it
as a guide
now the next thing we want to do is we
want to analyze do we have a horizontal
asymptote or a slant asymptote well in
this problem you see how the highest
degree determine the numerator is higher
than the
denominator's highest degree by one so
what that tells us is we're going to
have a slant asymptote like a diagonal
or an oblique asymptote how do we find
the equation of that oblique asymptote
or slant asymptote we're going to do
long division so I'm going to take the
numerator divided by the denominator so
we're seeing how many times is x squared
minus 2x minus 3 go into
2x cubed plus 3x squared
minus 2x Plus 0.
okay so you probably learned this before
polynomial long division how many times
is x squared go into 2x cubed that's
going to be 2x times I'm going to
distribute the 2x to all three of these
terms that's going to give us 2x cubed
minus 4x squared minus 6X you can
subtract or what some students like to
do is change the science to the opposite
and add so that's going to give us 7x
squared plus 4X plus 0. how many times
does x squared go into 7x squared that's
7 times if I distribute the 7 to all
three of these terms I get 7x squared
minus 14x minus 21. If I subtract or
change the science to the opposite and
add that's giving us 18x plus 21 and
when this degree x to the first is lower
than this degree x squared that's our
remainder we don't have to worry about
the remainder so our equation of our
slant asymptote is going to be y equals
2x Plus 7.
so that means it has a y intercept of 7
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 right about here a slope
of 2 which means I'm going to go rise to
run 1.
like this so down two over one cross
right about here let's repeat that down
two over one right about here down two
over one right about here
let's see down two over one right about
here so roughly uh let's repeat this a
little bit here up two over one
and up two over one up two okay so
basically
like this I'm trying to be accurate we
don't have graph paper here I don't have
graph paper on this screen here
on this board so we can just kind of
estimate like that
okay so now let's focus on the Y
intercept and the x-intercept so to find
the Y intercept we set x equal to zero
and if we put x equal to zero you can
see it's going to be zero over negative
three which is just zero so that tells
us it's going to go right through the
origin here let's put a point right
there
and the x-intercept we're going to set y
equal to zero now remember when Y is
equal to zero the only way that Y is
going to be equal to zero is if the
numerators factors are equal to zero so
that's going to occur at zero
one half
and negative 2.
so let's see let's plot that so zero one
half which is right about
here and negative 2 which is right about
here
okay so that's interesting and now some
additional points now we want to put
some points on either side of the
vertical asymptotes so let's maybe start
over here let's do a negative
1.5 so if we plug in negative 1.5 we're
going to do our sine analysis we're
going to get a negative
uh this is going to be a negative
this is going to be a positive
and then we've got a negative
and a negative okay so we get a positive
divided by positive which is a positive
so what that tells us is
that this graph is actually going to go
up towards positive Infinity right
here when we're just to the left of this
vertical asymptote
so what's happening here I don't know if
you can see this is this graph is
basically going like this
okay so as you go here is approaching
the slant asymptote but as it approaches
this way it's going up towards this
vertical asymptote so something like
that now let's approach this vertical
asymptote from this side let's say we
put in a negative a half
Okay negative 0.5 so what happens when
we do that we get a negative
this would be a negative
this would be a positive again
and this would be a positive so we're
getting a positive over a negative
which is a negative so that means from
this side it's going down towards
negative Infinity now if we approach
this vertical asymptote let's see one
two maybe like 2.5
what are we getting we're getting a
positive
we're getting a positive you can get the
exact number if you want this is just a
little quicker way of doing it and a
little bit more fun too I think so this
comes out to negative and this comes out
to a positive so we've got let's see a
positive negative which is a negative so
that tells us on this side we're going
down like this so here you can see that
this graph is going something like
this it crosses a little bit the x-axis
and it approaches these two asymptotes
now if we approach from this side let's
see one two three let's maybe put four
in
let's see what happens when we plug four
in we get
a positive
we get a positive
we get another positive
okay and then over here we get a
positive and a positive so you can see
everything is positive positive divided
by positive is a positive that tells us
from this side we're going to be going
up towards positive infinity and this
branch is going to go approach that
slant asymptote now here's the questions
that people are probably thinking
they're saying Mario how did you know it
bends right here like how do you how
come is it doesn't go all the way down
to right here and then go like that or
how come it doesn't bend over here this
is what you learn when you get to
calculus you're going to learn how to
find where the tangent line the slope of
the tangent line is zero and you're
going to be able to find exactly where
that minimum is or exactly where this
maximum is but for this video we're just
going to talk about getting a really
good sketch without being super precise
about some of these uh extremas they're
called these bends or Maxes or mins so
good job on this one this one was a
slant asymptote remember because the
degree in the numerator was one higher
than the highest power term in the
denominator let's look take a look at
two more examples okay before we dive
into these last two examples if you like
the way that I explain things and you
want to go deeper with your math
learning with me check out my algebra 1
and my algebra 2 slash college algebra
video courses for sale I take you step
by step through a typical algebra one or
college algebra curriculum and I'll put
a links in the description below also if
you just want to support the videos that
I'm putting up here on my Myers math
tutoring YouTube channel consider
joining as a channel member so for a few
dollars a month you can support the
videos that I'm putting up here and I
really appreciate that I see every
member that comes through with a channel
name or the the name of your you know
your YouTube handle and I can see you
know that you're you're a member of the
channel and I really appreciate that and
then lastly if you just want to purchase
one of my fun math t-shirts you'll see
below the video I've got some links to
my Teespring store so you can purchase
one of those t-shirts if you want to
just kind of have some fun with my
channel here so let's dive into number
four and number five so for number four
we've got f of x is equal to 3 over x
squared plus one so what's our first
step first step is always to factor as
much as you can but in this in this case
we cannot actually Factor this so okay
we don't have to worry about that so now
what about the holes are there any
factors that cancel with the numerator
in the denominator well in this case no
so we're going to say no holes here
how about vertical asymptotes vertical
asymptotes is when we set the
denominator equal to zero if we set the
denominator equal to zero let's just do
that for a moment
subtract one from both sides take the
square root the square root of a
negative number you get imaginary
numbers so that tells you that there's
actually no vertical asymptotes
on this graph so this is kind of a
little bit different than the first
three now for letter C horizontal
asymptote or a slant asymptote here's
where we analyze the highest power term
in the numerator and the highest power
term in the denominator so in this case
you can see because the degree of the
highest term in the denominator is
higher than the numerator
the horizontal asymptote is going to be
y equals zero which is right here on the
x-axis
and again you can think about this as X
gets really large like say for example
if x was like a hundred a hundred
squared is ten thousand plus one is ten
thousand and one what's three divided by
ten thousand and one it's like .00 you
know it's all approaching zero basically
right
so now for letter D the Y intercept so
to find the Y intercept we set x equal
to zero and if we do that we're going to
get three over one which is three so
that means that this graph is going to
cross right here at zero comma three the
x-intercept we set the y coordinate to
zero so if we set y equal to zero that's
like zero over one
and if we cross multiply here we get 3
times 1 is 3 is equal to zero which
doesn't make sense three can't equal 0.
so that tells us that there's really no
x-intercepts
okay so it's not crossing the x-axis
and then let's plot some additional uh
points now normally I'll pick some
points on either side of the vertical
asymptote but there's not a vertical
asymptote so let's just pick some points
that you know on either side of this
y-axis let's just do let's say for
example a negative 3 and positive 3. so
if I put in negative 3
I get negative 3 squared is 9 plus 1 is
10 3 over 10.
and if I plug in positive 3 I also get
three tenths so that's interesting so
negative 3
3 10 is right about here and positive
three three tenths is right about here I
can plot some additional points as well
like maybe let's plot a negative one and
one
that would give us uh 1.5 and 1.5
so that's going to be right about here
and right about here so you can see this
graph is basically it's going like this
where it's
approaching the x-axis as you go to the
left it's approaching the x-axis as you
go to the right
and it's like a symmetric if you fold
over the y-axis it's going to match to
itself so this is a little bit different
graph let's take a look at one last
example okay let's dive into example
number five and if you want more
practice with these problems I'll put a
link at this end of this video I'll
indicate where you can click to see some
other video that I did previously
talking about how to graph these
rational functions
but for number five how we graph this
one well this one we notice that we need
to factor it first as much as we can so
I notice I can factor out an X as a
greatest common factor in the numerator
and the denominator looks like we can
factor into two binomials what
multiplies to two but adds to negative
three that's going to be negative 2 and
negative one and it looks like I can
Factor this numerator a little bit
further X plus 3 x minus 2 over x minus
1 x minus 2. I notice I just flipped
these and so notice here that there's a
factor in the numerator that cancels
with the factor in the denominator so
that tells us that there's going to be a
hole in our graph right and that x
coordinate of the whole if we set this
equal to zero x minus two equals zero X
is equal to two so we're going to have a
whole
at when the x is equal to 2. now how do
we find the y coordinate we take that 2
and we plug it back in so that's going
to be let's see 2 times 5 is 10 over 2
minus 1 which is one so that comes out
to 10 over 1 which is 10. so let's see
on our graph here 210 that's going to be
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 right about here
okay is our whole now for the vertical
asymptotes we want to set the
denominator equal to zero because we
can't divide by zero that's undefined so
if I set this equal to zero that means
that x equals 1 would be our vertical
asymptote so that's going to be right
here
let's draw this as a dashed or dotted
line right through x equals 1.
and then for our horizontal or slant
asymptote which one do you think it is
well notice that the degree in the
numerator is one higher than the highest
power term in the denominator that tells
us we're going to have a slant or a
diagonal asymptote and the way that you
find the equation that asymptote is to
do some long division so we're going to
figure out how many times does x squared
minus 3x plus 2
go into the numerator X cubed plus x
squared minus 6X plus 0. so x squared
goes into X cubed x times if I'm going
to distribute the X to all three of
these terms that's going to give us X
cubed minus 3x squared plus 2X subtract
or you can change the signs to the
opposite and add so that gives us 4x
squared minus 8x plus 0. how many times
does x squared go into 4x squared that's
4 times if I distribute the 4 to all
these terms
I get
this and if I subtract which is like
changing the signs to the opposite and
adding
we get 4X minus 8 and notice that this
is X to the first this is x squared
normally what we do is we put our
remainder over our divisor right when we
do our long division but what happens is
a c as X gets larger and larger this
whole fraction is going to go to zero
because the degree in the numerator is
higher than the degree in the
the degree the denominator is higher
than the degree in the numerator so this
whole thing goes to zero that's why I
say we don't have to worry about the
remainder our slant asymptotes just
going to be the line Y equals X Plus 4.
so let's see if we can graph that on our
graph we have a y intercept of 4 and a
slope of one so it's going to go like
this
uh try to be accurate here as much as I
can
something like this
okay there's our slant asymptote now
let's analyze our Y intercept and our
x-intercepts what I like to do is make a
table and you set the opposite variable
to zero so if I want the Y intercept I
put 0 in for X if I put 0 in for X you
can see I'm going to get 0 over 2 which
is 0. so that means it's going to go
right through our origin here at 0 0.
if I want to find the x-intercept I set
the y equal to zero now the only way
that Y is going to equal 0 here is if
the numerators factors are zero so that
would occur at zero and negative 3.
so that means it's going to cross at 0
and negative 3
okay right here and then let's plot some
additional points now the key points are
the points on either side of the
vertical asymptote because remember it's
like a brick wall it either has to go
down to negative Infinity up through
positive Infinity can't go through the
brick wall right so let's maybe plot a
half so if we put a half in
what happens we get a positive
positive which is going to give us a
positive when you multiply over a
negative a positive by negative is a
negative so that tells us it's going to
go down like this so we can see what's
happening here the graph's going like
this
and like this
approaching that slant asymptote getting
closer and closer now if we pick a point
on this side let's say for example like
two
that's going to give us a positive
positive which is a positive over 2
minus 1 which is positive one that's a
positive a positive positive is a
positive so from this side it tells us
this graph is going to go up towards
positive Infinity now this graph is
going to go something like
this okay now again we talked about this
in a previous example
we don't know exactly where this graph
is bending without using calculus we
have to find out where the slope of the
tangent line is equal to zero to find
these X from these maximums and minimums
but for this video for this what we're
doing here we're just getting a basic
sketch we've got our intercepts we've
got our asymptotes we've got our holes
we've got some you know sign analysis to
tell us that the graph's going up to the
right or down to the right up you know
with the asymptotes where it's
approaching
Etc so great job I hope you picked up
some good pointers in this lesson but if
you want more practice follow me over to
that video right there where we dive
into some more examples graphing
rational functions I'll see you in that
video